this is the first time zebenesa has
returned to her home
since she and her family fled for their
lives
it is completely destroyed
zebenisa is kyrgyz she has lived in the
village of cocktash
on the disputed border with tajikistan
all her life
there have been clashes between the
kyrgyz and tajik communities
in this region before but never has
military involvement left destruction on
this scale
i had hope that when i came back there
would be something left
but i'm devastated god willing with help
of the people we will rebuild our lives
instead of moving i want to rebuild here
this place has always been home i will
never leave
both the kyrgyz and tajik governments
accuse each other of escalating the
situation
videos shot on mobile phones show the
tajik military moving into disputed
villages
no tajik homes were destroyed in the
attacks
in this village this is one of 17 homes
in this particular village that has been
destroyed and people have begun to come
back
to inspect the damage or in this case
what remains
of their properties and one thing they
all tell you is that there was no
animosity in the community
during the period of the soviets
problems
started with the breakup of the soviet
union independence
and a border problem that has lasted 30
years
the violence was sparked by arguments
between local kyrgyz and tajik residents
over control of water from this
reservoir
kyrgyzstan says tajik soldiers killed
more than 50 people
destroyed government and private
property
inspects the damage to his home
we are afraid my family and children
can't live here
my tajik neighbors were also evacuated
but into their territory
the relationship between us has not been
good for years but now it's worse than
ever
some of the estimated 60 000 people who
were evacuated are sheltering in schools
i've been here with my sister-in-law and
grandchildren for four days
i don't know what's happening in my
village thank god we are being looked
after here
with little sign of a comprehensive
settlement to this complicated border
dispute
zebenesa and many like her will struggle
to rebuild their lives charles stratford
al jazeera
coqtash on the kirigis tajik border